hello the Internet I'm Gavin down where
the slow mo guys and we've had a lot of
requests by you for drums yeah I got the
hands on a secondhand war drum pretty
much from this massive big old big old
bass drum yeah and a symbol and now
we're gonna film in slo-mo you should
see the frequency moving through them
and maybe we'll art it up a little bit
yeah got some different color powder
paints put some liquids on there see
what all looks like yeah yeah so uh
should we see what we can drum up from
black to black no maybe like a couple of
inches in from black to white
so like wider channels have more color
yeah like this I'll get a bit of that on
there blood do that orange is mental so
fine it's the finest powder pin I've
ever seen in my life okay it's great
from the bag on that one straight from
the bag palsy-walsy move okay so we'll
start off filming at a thousand foots in
4k
it should look top of the morning bloody
lovely
so I want to see it from the top down
but it's all immediately going to flat
focus and let's flip us it sort of
predictably let's say it goes at the top
of it that's where it finishes so maybe
like here maybe hit yeah go for it ready
lovely looks cool
that's that is a really cool gradient of
colors there look at it so hit it from
one side we'll see if we can see the
shock wave travel very good
all right I want to see this slightly
faster so I switched the resolution to
HD which will give us about 2000 fps
so we've got a lot of good footage from
hitting it on the top of the drum so
we're gonna try and we'll see what it
looks like hitting it from the
underneath of the membrane I imagine
it's very different in a minute the
membrane thing will work
I feel like this this one what we've
done so far the vibration kicks it all
out this one the impact will kick it up
and so it will be centered on one point
they are a hit basically oh god scary
just really really bright it's like
magnifying the sudden you find the back
door look up Hey
what interesting problem to have I
didn't think this was gonna be so much
better an obstacle this filming this
video
I didn't predict this either
it's very different I want to try
filming it from further back okay with
the slower camera but I think what you
should do is just make because you can
only hit one spot make one mound but
layer all the colors on top of each
other okay just so a big pile of all the
different colors in the middle yeah via
the reset time on this one not too bad
how much do you want hey I'd say you
know like the egg in an egg mcmuffin
yeah about that size okay
relative to the rest of the McMuffin
yeah what do you mean do you mean
including bread or no no just the egg
part of the muffin okay I understand you
might sheet you might be better off just
cutting the air the bottom off a cup
stacking it and take the cup off I don't
like that idea because you thought of it
yep it's the purple
my face looks nice in your face his
haircut
all right drum look good let's let's
move on to symbol and a stick that white
card you got right behind you this is
what it looks like okay I like that a
lot better than random jungle yeah you
see the colors better I suppose as well
yeah
all right so we've moved over to the
shed because that's still in the Sun and
will actually try paint on the white
background this time because we forgot
you know
well Dan I think that was some lovely
looking footage I'm actually a bit
gutted I don't have a 4k TV to watch it
on but hopefully some of you do and let
me know how it was tweet it to me or
something so I can't your hair looks
stupid it's ridiculous you got me you've
actually like annihilated me it's very
rare that I'm the one who gets messy
actually less messy some oh my god we
can't be over that all right you have to
do something about that be sure to
follow us on Twitter buy a shirt have
one of them and also subscribe to the
second channel where they'll be behind
the scenes stuff actually devastated
that I'm the message don't clean
yourself up and I'm just special thanks
to new egg and W D for sending me these
two nests drives basically 48 terabytes
of hard drive storage that I can access
over my network the phantom cameras
shoot around 16 gigabytes per real-time
second so as you can imagine I'm
constantly in need of additional
harddrive space so this really helps me
out there's a link to them in the
description if you're interested